we stand like one austria stands for
a strong europe that protects freedom and
at the same time the law and
as i never tire of emphasizing
is precisely why the area of
justice is an important contact
[music]
that the rule of law in the european
union also in the area of ​​justice and  around
200,000 insolvencies occur
every year
and 1.7 million
jobs are lost as a result.
our goal is therefore to
prevent
insolvencies
Measures are taking exactly this
direction.
I am therefore pleased that the
money laundering directive could also be adopted
today by removing
obstacles to cross-border
cooperation, such as the cooperation
between national states and
authorities, and
finally the pres  jurisprudence aligned with
international obligations
evans aim
is to improve cross-border
access to electronic evidence
to effectively combat
cybercrime or crime
using the internet
[music]
the action